AS WE GO TO OUR
NEXT GAME EASY & GREASY.
EASY & GREASY.
SPEND ANY TIME ON THE FACEBOOK
AND YOU'LL BE EYEBALL-(BLEEP) BY
ADS FOR ALL THESE TRENDY NEW
DELIVERABLE MEAL PLANS LIKE BLUE
APRON.
UH, IT'S JUST PICS OF
RELENTLESSLY HAPPY PEOPLE IN
WELL-LIT KITCHENS JUST HAVING A
GOOD OLD TIME IN NON-LOGOED
CLOTHING, COOKING UP THE LATEST
BALSAMIC BOK CHOY RECIPE OR SOME
VAGUELY NAMED FOOD SERVICE LIKE
"PLATED" OR "FRESHLY" OR
"WHITELY PEOPLELY LOVELY
THISLY."
UH, AND BY THE WAY, (BLEEP) IS
EXPENSIVE, SO, COMEDIANS, I WANT
YOU TO COME UP WITH AS MANY
NAMES FOR LOW-RENT MEAL PLANS
THAT YOU'D NEVER WANT TO
SUBSCRIBE TO IN 60 SECONDS, AND
BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
SPIKE.
>> DOG HAIR AND PENNIES.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
ALISON.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S NOT
GARBAGE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
SPIKE.
>> REDDISH LOBSTER.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
SPIKE.
>> (BLEEP) STUFFERS.
(HARDWICK LAUGHS)
>> HARDWICK: THAT IS THE WORST
PHRASE I'VE EVER HEARD IN MY
LIFE.
>> AND YOU WOULDN'T ORDER IT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS.
FITZY.
>> BIG BOX OF BULL(BLEEP).
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
ALISON.
>> CHEF BOYARDON'T.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
SPIKE.
>> ARTHUR TREACHER'S FISH AND
USED TAMPONS.
(BUZZING)
I'M GRASPING HERE, BUT I KNEW
THEY WOULD LIKE THAT ONE.
I KNEW...
>> HARDWICK: YOU KNOW...
>> BIG ARTHUR TREACHER FANS.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
PERFECT.
THAT'S THE END OF EASY & GREASY.